I have this shiny thing with higher
scores for cool that guys not cool into
the house no rust you you okay tonight
you're going to blame him what if Adams
lying to you what if I'm not lying I
always ate the day of reckoning
basically the sky falls cuz he's not
lying you want I told you I saw your
window come on yeah hey hey paper oh I
missed hey you should this is on Airbnb
mark I'll totally hook this no no come
on if you can hit me I'll totally let
you give a chance fine
we need we meet again at some other
point with my knife
oh it means not music the sky you're
killing spree dude if you don't have if
you don't have an ID you're practically
a bystander so you're totally better now
I'll just say that I'm on the other team
now yeah yeah all right where did your
knife go
why you still try to kill me ups right
because you brought this upon yourself
you let him to me with the gun and you
said that hey he's the murderer she just
you kill him it's wrong me uh-oh
that was a sign miss Holly why did I
pick it up Wow
hey you you order other than this blog
you should probably try to listen more
eared I'm the worst
I'm the worst shot okay just stop moving
for a second Marsh we can hit you no no
no show me
don't shoot me with my device to me I
want to eat and talk about life right
and I shoot one of us rent your oranges
so I've perfect this is my amazing meal
it's oranges and water and bananas okay
cymatics please you coming up yeah maybe
if we line up in one you can get both of
our heads in the same [ __ ] I don't shoot
us at the same valid let's do that all
right kite
oh there actually is a dungeon space
down here whoa I mean you there boy the
place with the van I've opened it we're
going in you better fix
there is a Dodger taste hang on a memo
Wow what the hell
all right all right I shot you I tried
my best but it wasn't good enough yeah
yeah where's this tunnel my cat is very
unsettled she's Mia hydro love high your
kilo but I okay mark the other mark did
the math hey what happened do you need
to see here
don't talk God bleed or lighten up on
these guys my sex dungeon listen no no
no no mark mark mark mark it's cool come
on sex dungeon in here what bar god yeah
hate engine of discovery come on
that kilo gave me okay it's it's dark
the roof of what you for those how does
destiny mm-hmm let's roof house hey
there's my roof hey hey there's my roof
roof all right anybody on my roof I was
murder last time so statistically
speaking it is unlikely that I am the
murder to be premised I've no idea who
who is so I'm just gonna assume that
you're all me master God I'm Romeo I'm
Romeo I don't believe you not for one
second we all do we believe the
statistics whose statistics are nine
media okay totally not trust me that's
logic probability and whatnot but you
see he likes to get closer to you and
that's a telltale sign that he is the
right man
whoa take the gun mark run to the sex
that you crazy
I'm blind see oh okay
I'm very dead Oh the sex Tenjin dear
look right so we're all here there's one
person missing
I'm not yellow I'm not the murderer I
just don't know where my minutes left or
can only mean one thing I'm lost I see
what I mean you did it again
you guys said the stairs and try to
negotiate with he's lost or he's gay I'm
gonna go talk to him in the tunnels
somewhere I've no idea we're always in
the SEC's gonna hide I'm just gonna hide
just leave me in the sex dungeon let's
try and let's try and negotiate a treaty
why is it where's the sex dungeon again
this way such as this way okay you going
okay oh this is not good yes Oh God who
just that we follow him cuz that was a
really dumb idea
oh you know what at least I tried dining
again that's what matters the paints a
clearly shot off oh I know what you're
talking about hutch I'm getting it too
because the blood came out of his
general region uh-huh my genital region
generals dick is located my general
genital region I'm tango and obviously I
am innocent like come on we obviously
well stay by one of you guys and say you
guys can stand all behind me I will
pretty darn close to another okay back
on feet I got my boys here if we all
touch it will feel yeah yeah yeah it's
the dog pound now Delta Oh firearm and I
got it it's my first knife throw that
actually work well that's good I love it
mark I hope you're happy with yourself
which am very happy Mike him
okay which one mark uh uh Sally we're so
Oh me I'm Sally what you know so I am
the law I am November and I have the law
I told you is trustworthy i'ma stand
right here listen go back to [ __ ]
[ __ ] you'll see no no I'm gonna build
trust with you shoot me no no it's
obviously not me just do it okay
all right just shoot him please no what
do you what do you want I'm just tired
I told you to kill the truck India
please shoot him thank you oh my god
hahahaha
I was trying to push the button but no
it didn't happen
hello let's go stare into his soul
yeah everybody just look at him yeah hi
hi I think that he's here now who's got
the gun I don't have it uh I don't I
don't know okay hello Lee touch have the
gun and one of you is the murderer I'm
not a murderer I'm Han murderer oh god
don't you guys there's no winning this
okay I'm gonna totally simplify for
everyone all right that when they
understand one possibility oh oh well
there you go
he bounced
oh he ragequit had the murderer rage
quit the chat says I thought you guys
were ignoring me I'm so alone
my watch is over okay I got enough for
another egg I'm gonna make another baby